a ton of you are interested in valor n't
and we're giving you the basic rundown
so you can understand what this game is
all about valor n't is a character based
tactical shooter by Riot Games the folks
that make team fight tactics and of
course League of Legends it combines
aspects of Counter Strike global
Offensive Rainbow six siege and
overwatch and is currently running a
closed beta the heroes environment are
called agents and there are five to
start off with and an additional five to
unlock each agent in the beta fills a
role initiators disrupt choke points in
order to let their team get into
contested spaces duelists are multi-role
fighters that focus on frags and
aggressive pushing sentinels help to
fortify locations such as sites where
you can plant the spike controllers have
area-denial attacks designed to split up
combat spaces in order to divide and
conquer
time-to-kill is fast in this game so
you'll have a small window to react and
get abilities off than in a game like
overwatch you'll also probably be
familiar with some of these abilities
from other games such as orbital strikes
elemental walls and spy cameras the
current mode in the beta pits teams of
five against each other until one team
reaches 13 wins your team will be
assigned to either defend or attack the
objective for the first 12 rounds before
switching sides you win a round either
by wiping out the enemy team or by
planting the spike and guarding it until
it detonates
there's a csgo style buying phase at the
start of each round where you can
purchase weapons armor and charges for
your agents unique abilities in the
beats at the economy is pretty forgiving
with a loss netting you 1,900 points a
win 3,000 points and kills around 200
each that means you'll be stocked with
low to mid tier weapons consistently
presuming you don't overspend on the
more expensive weapons in our experience
some of the higher level sniper rifles
can begin to dominate but the game is
still in its early stages so the meta is
still developing it's important to
recognize the benefit of certain tactics
and systems for example moving slowly
will cancel out the sound of your
footsteps and is a must make sure you
reserve Sprint for when you're already
engaged certain guns such as rifles and
SMGs rifles will allow aiming down
sights with different damage numbers
depending on how you shoot another thing
to keep in mind is how each agents
ultimate ability charges if you die in a
round win or lose you will gain one alt
point although how many points you need
before you use your alt varies by agent
other ways you gain out points involve
capturing the silver or black orbs that
spawn in-game planting or defusing the
spiked bomb and getting kills the maps
we've seen so far tend to have longer
sightlines on the outer edges and close
to medium engagements at the center
remaining delete no.1 pain target there
are plenty of choke points for teams to
pile up plenty of lanes for agents with
a sniper rifle to lock down and many
tight corners to keep eyes on the number
of bomb sites can vary per map the rules
stay the same once a team finds a spike
the other must diffuse or lose even if
they wipe the defending team Valery also
comes with a pretty handy training area
where you can try every weapon and even
raise or lower mouse sensitivity in game
we haven't found any controller support
yet but for those brushing up on their
mouse and keyboard twitch skills the
training area is a must especially when
the game rewards headshots significantly
more than body shots there is also a
microtransaction area already available
to sell you skins and buddies you can
also earn buddies sprays cards titles
and some gunskins by leveling agent
contracts although the microtransaction
store will have exclusive goodies we'll
have plenty more tips and excellent
content soon as we cover this much hyped
game so definitely stay tuned and check
out our other video guides and feature
articles valor --nt is scheduled to
release this summer 2020 last player
standing
attackers win